Guys
I've been inside the closet
for days,
but I think I-
I think I found a way.
What?
There's so much space here!
Marzia! You're in here as well?
Damn, we have a lot of unused storage space
There's another door inside the clos-
Where does this go?
What.. What?!
This is so spacious!
Marzia.. Can you believe, this has been inside all [this time]?
Marzia: Oh..Yeah! Impressive..!
We can store so much!
Okay, something is definitely.. wrong here.
Why is there a completely different city, in my closet?
This is epic guys!
Alright, that's getting annoying now.. alright, we're on holiday.
I think we're in.. Budapest?
And uhh.. it's pretty.. it's pretty epic
What do you think Marzia?
Marzia: Mm-hmm
She says mm-hmm
Marzia: I like it, it looks so pretty
Yeah, it's...
It's a city.
Sponsor!
Hey, look, it's the mini Orion!
LCD
Let's give it a go
live feed
Look at that
Can you see this?
You're looking at this?
Haha! It's pretty good! It's a good di-display.. there we go!
Woah.
Oh no..
It's my first one!
It's pretty good
Look at that
Alright, are you ready for the flip, Marzia?
Marzia: Mhmm!
We should--what button is the flip?
Alright, here we go
Woah!
You see that?
Marzia: Yeah!
You wanna see another flip, Marzia?
Marzia: Wait.. go higher?
Another flip, here we go.. Woah, front flip!!
Alright, let me record video...
That's right, it records video!
Let's get a flip in front of these guys and impress them
*Marzia giggles*
Hey guys, wait! You're missing out on the flip.
Hey, you see that?
*Marzia laughs*
They saw it
That's right, everybody.
Alright, we'll do some more with it later.
Okay, so now we're going to Gilette Spa.. which is like a thermal bath spa thing.
Very nice.
Alright, this is the part where usually you would add--just--background music
--like any other vlogger, but I can't be bothered--
--to find the right fitting track and sync it all up. So here you go.
Here's some footage of Hungary... there's a boat--
--went pretty fast. I thought I'd film it.
There's a girl that waved at me at the ferry and I tried to wave back and realized I just ruined the shot.
but here you go that's a- that's a nicer one. Alright.
Umm.. Budapest, is very pretty.
Very pretty buildings and stuff.
But where are all the bit[@!%}]?
I don't..
Marzia: What?!
I didn't mean it.
So, we're going there.
Very nice.
Oh, you see the pool?
I doubt I'm able to film, but I'm probably gonna do it anyway... LP style
So pretty.
Damn.
Look at this!
Very nice.
Alright, let's try it out
I'm going in.
Oooh! It's nice and hot!
Happy Anniversary!
Marzia: Happy Anniversary!
Look how beautiful!
It's amazing..!
This is the outdoor area. There you go everybody, now you've seen it.
What would you rate the baths?
I liked it, I would give it an 8/10
Maybe even a 9
Damn
What?
That's pretty good.
What would you do?
I don't rate things. That's not what I do.
Okay..
But it was good.
Alright, we're checking out of this castle, it's literally right here.
There you go everybody. Hope you enjoy that.
I would rate it a one-
I mean..
SPONSOR !!!
Woah, isn't that cool, Marzia?
$69.99, everybody.
Casey Neistat is crying right now. How did he get his hands on this advanced technology?
Can we add a picture of Casey crying?
Oh Yeah
Oh YEAH!
Front flip!
Woah!
Nearly killed her!
*both laughing*
..like, actually, almost killed someone
Don't worry, you're safe. I'm really good at this.
*Marzia chuckles*
*Felix laughs*
The mini Orion LCD: $69.99
Good morning. It's another day in Hungary and guess what?
Marzia: We're here for breakfast
Felix: We're hungry [hungary]
There's a national holiday today, so we're told it's gonna be very busy, and loud.. which it is.
Woah!
Is he coming down?
Woah! He's falling!
Woah..
This is the Parliament
This is the line to enter.. What is this? TANACON?
No thank you!
Shut up, child...
Hello everybody, this is me reporting in.
I am now on a bicycle as you can see
will be upd--Oh, I got recognized
Hey man!
Really nice uhh--fans here in Hungary. Everyone's been really cool and chill, I like it.
This is---everything else is a mess.
We're going to Buda castle now
Reporting there.
Oh my god
We have to go through there?
Maybe the bikes wasn't the best idea.
Okay. So we're in the line to go up there.. to get to the Buda Castle.
I'm really glad I'm wearing all black, really good choice, cause I'm not hot.. at all [intense sarcasm].
Looks like we got a cameo in this vlog.
Here we are guys.. in the cabin.
This is epic!
Alright, beautiful--shot of Budapest.
It's a, there-. Oh, there we go. There's your first bridge--
--for all the IDIOTS that walked up.
Yeah
Alright
and then
There's the other bridge--
for all the MORONS--
--that decided that you were gonna walk up that hill
Pfff...
losers..
And there's how it looks like going down
It was--
It was okay, I guess.
I like this statue. It was very epic. It looks way better in person.
Uhh... and there's a HA kid.
I don't know why I'm filming these! I just thought it would be nice...
Ohhh boy.. so tonight is fireworks.
But you know what we're gonna do now, Marzia?
*unintelligible whine* [sleep well?]
Before that.. see if the drone can flip inside!
Should we do it?
Don't do this.
YEAH BOI !
Marzia: I didn't get it
You didn't get it?
Marz: I was hiding
It was so good... ok ok..
Got it.
(Oh, yeah. Yeah)
Okay
Holy---
It's only been more busy, how is this possible?
This is crazy
We're now joining the parade.
Marzia says she really wanted to-
Felix's flashback voiceover: So I'm looking forward, but I'm not looking in the camera
*Felix laughing* It makes--
-- Ok, there's nothing wrong with my eyes. Don't worry... maybe...
Our restaurant is over th-
Felix's flashback voiceover: What is happening? What is this?
-there basically
We have no choice
You can't see me, that's cool. You can see the top of my head, that's all you need to see.
Here I am.
Oh
It was better without. It was better without.
Oh, you're taking a picture?
We're waiting for the fireworks to start. They're supposed to start.
Everyone is talking about the fireworks. They start in 10 minutes.
Are you excited?
Marzia: Yea
Yeah!
Oh no, that's my face. Oh no, Marzia I'm doing it wrong!
Okay, Marzia, I figured it out.
Oh no.. I missed it.
Oh my god, it's the halo theme
(Imitates music) ahh ahh ahh ahh ahh--
It's coming
It's going crazy!!
Woah! woah.. WOAH!
Marzia, help!
woah!
oh
oh oh oh OH! woah...
*crowd cheers* hey!
Congratulations, Hungary, for your Independence!
Well done!
You deserve it!
Good morning
Last day in Budapest
We're back on the bikes
And uhh--we're going to the Market!
Yeayy
These bikes are really bad
It's really hard to cycle on them
And considering how it went yesterday, I'm amazed that we're still on it.
There it is
*Russian National Anthem plays* I knew it
How to be a real Hungarian: get a cool hat.
Marzia, do you want to get one?
Nope
It has cum in it, eww
okay.
Marzia: look at those snakes..!
oh yeah
Oh my god
She just gave it to me...
He's so awesome. Yeah
His hands are so awesome
Look at it
He's climbing, ha. Stop climbing.
Oh.. you can't go there
oh no! oh no.
Oh my god! so cute!
Cute, heheh.
Turtle: leave a like on this video, thank you!
Sorry
*makes guinea pig dance to Demi Lovato*
Alright that was really cool, bit random.
We're going to eat lunch now, in case anyone is curious what we're doing.
Marzia: You always walk away from me!
Alright so now we're gonna eat lunch. I really look forward to it
And it's gonna be gre--
Woah
What's going on here?
What is this?
Fun thing about Budapest is that taxi drivers will not take you anywhere. They told us they don't want to go because he doesn't want to turn around
First he thought we were going somewhere else and I insisted, like, no we're not going there
We're going over there and he's like "well I don't want to go there" and I'm like "why? I don't want to turn."
Marzia
Huh.. ME!
This is me. Oh my god. This is me...
Marzia, this is so me.
This is totally me right now.
Plants..
plants..
..plants
demonetized
plants..
*bird noises*
All right, we are here in the place. This is where the shoes are, look at that, there's so many shoes!
So these are from the war... with people leaving notes in them
Leaving candles in em.
It's been a really nice trip. Very nice. Very fine trip, I would say.
What do you think, Marzia?
Marzia: Yea it was great!
It was great
Alright, that's it for the Budapest vlog. Hope you guys enjoyed it, leave a like if you did!
We're taking the plane back now.. in a.. few hours.
wait
*ominous scifi music*
Marzia, there's a portal in here!
I see.. I see the bedroom.
I see, oh my god. There's something here, Marzia come with m--